foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
do the class and everything yeah I mean
[Music]
foreign
first hearing that five teams were
interested it whittled its way down to
two
and then about a week ago finally one
came forward and said right we're ready
to sign you come out here and let's talk
I'm signing for a full year
good time for longer but to be honest
contract over a year out here is not
worth poker it's written on if something
goes wrong out here you only get a
couple of months to walk away anyway so
but it does give you the option after 12
months that if you do do really well
you can ask for more money and
renegotiate your contract I'm very
pleased to be sitting here as head coach
going into the new season you know
there'll be some ups and downs along the
way I'm sure the injury suspensions and
refereeing decisions that we'll all talk
about
but at the end of the day everything we
do from here on here is about winning
[Applause]
[Music]
where do you begin with the problem of
Indonesian football there's been decades
and Decades of scandals
corruption fans dying watching the game
violence in the game the usage of
governmental funding which makes it very
political which makes it very easy for
match fixing to take place that's been
going on for decades and decades and
decades
players officials staff they actually
don't get paid on time you know and it's
not like two or three days delays like
talking about between three to eight
months some players cannot really
support their family anymore and
somebody come okay would you like to
give up a game for just ten thousand
dollars I mean it's very easy for them
to take I mean you don't get paid you
get an easy money which one you take
[Music]
please give way to a lighting passengers
voice
[Music]
how does how much money is needed to
ensure that uh Mali do what you say with
Willy about
Magic
dollars which is a lot of money for
African country yes yes
okay it ends here there are others it's
in my book all the transcripts that we
put in the book and how much betting for
a game one million for the 2010 World
Cup uh warm-up qualifiers
so it's crazy man it's big money
fixing is not only for gambling not only
for money but it could be for honor it
can be for political ends and so on so
there are many dimensions to match
fixing and it depends on what you want
to get out of it
[Music]
fun
contractor
we're good enough
physio no assistant manager no
goalkeeper coach yeah disappointing with
the organization to be honest you can
only work with the tools you've given I
make you tired they make you
then I make you pass let's just say it
needs to improve it needs to improve it
if this is going to be a challenging
Club in Indonesia they're signing a lot
of players so to be honest the pressure
on me is ramping up in Indonesia a week
my first time working at this level in
the country and uh
yeah the names are saying to me now he
expects to win the league so
[Music]
as you do I suppose we spend that much
money but it's just possible this this
is something I forget all the time they
pray before the game
there's me chatting away through their
prayer and they're all waiting for me to
stop talking so I've got to get used to
that can't work out well it's certainly
not Catholic so I'm not sure what
religion is
coaches have to overcome so many
problems here that other coaches in
Europe don't have to factors that has
nothing to do with football they're
actually sums up whether you're
successful or not you know foreigners
whether in football or not they have to
adjust and they just have to they just
have to go with it
but you do need a thick skin
in terms of match fixing that it is
happening and that's happening very very
often
and years after years continuously that
is a fact
what do you bet for Indonesia or
Malaysia
well but I think he's got a lot of money
here tonight for that game
[Music]
you see that but you just cannot prove
that
he's just gonna prove that
and um you will have a hunch you will
notice it you will think about it it's
like
this is this is a case this is gonna be
a case but you just can't prove it
in a situation like a match fixing and
stuff the official will not be
approached
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
I tell Simon I cannot speak in English
good but I learned English with English
music sometimes I
problem but I always learned at the time
difference here yeah okay meaning
every time I see this I like
because
um
foreign
[Music]
make them run
okay you play with a little bit of
common sense if you lose ball loose ball
don't chase get back in have shape safe
come on then
okay conserve energy and defense use
energy going forward
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
but we lost to a [__] team
they're not good enough to beat us
but they have Now understand one thing
my teams do not stop
[Music]
you play for my team you fight until
94th 95th 96th minute you don't just
slow down
today was more about me learning
and them learning about me and less
really about the result I thought the
team we play against were good team
but um I think what we showed we we
showed that we have a lot of ability
and we will get better and better and
better today was today was just about
learning it was it was about
understanding yourself I'm happy I don't
like to lose never like to lose but
as far as what I've taken away from the
game I learned an awful lot about
players today so that's good
[Music]
I've been plucked from relative
security and you know rhyming South and
being given an opportunity like a
national team of the Philippines and
succeeding with that and taking them to
a their highest FIFA rankings they've
ever been in in their history
Underdog Story I'm not I'm not a name
I'm not a Premiership manager I've not
worked in England at a particularly high
level but I've been given an opportunity
and I'm hugely thankful for everyone
that just wanted me to do well and
it was an amazing feeling to come out of
that with success
[Music]
the guys who work first team coaches in
the Premiership who've never been
anywhere near a national team and I'd
like to think I'd get another
international team job eventually but I
need to take advantage of the
opportunity that was given to me and I
need to to like I say
push it as hard as I can
to make a career out of it
[Music]
results
when Simon first went to the Philippines
football was not a popular sport they
didn't have their own League they didn't
have their own stadium they had a
national team that weren't competitive
Simon came in and changed all that and
you know that's going to be like
probably one of the biggest successes of
his whole career oh it's tough It's it's
not easy and sometimes
you know we might take
niggle at each other and take things out
on each other because there isn't really
anyone else that you you know when
you're at home you've got your family
you've got
friends you've got a massive support
network but here Simon and I literally
vent at each other
Simon's like oh it's you know we're on
the same team and we are but it's it's
difficult
[Music]
come back to the manufacturing or
arranging a game it's all possible
because players might decide just to do
anything to get something for himself
small bonuses to live you know so yeah
we did just just a small try you know
try out to see how simple or how easy
how easy it is actually maybe to to uh
to buy a player or to um to give some
money out to um for him to do something
in the game you know so we're asking the
this particular player we're talking
about the goalkeeper over here we have
three schemes for him whenever he get
the first ball in the game he will just
kick it out to the stand anywhere
for a throw out the second one he has to
do is just to fake an injury in the last
10 minutes of the game basically asking
for substitution now if the the coach
has uses three substitution and they're
in winning position we'll ask him to let
the goal in basically only in winning
position yeah you just want to see
whether it works or not
I'm sure you want to prove that it can
be done easily we've been getting proof
from the horse's mouth in terms of
secretly recorded conversations
sms's WhatsApp but fixing a game I think
it's a bit too much yeah
two ballsy man
[Music]
if you look out and see how happy the
fans are you know they're supporting
their Club all the way to the end
they're ready to die for the club for
the players and um at the end the the
club themselves or the players some of
them just basically betray them
you know betray them
Indonesia has got the best fans they're
just amazingly loyal and and they just
long for their national team to
to win and be successful and I and I
just don't see this as just soccer you
have to understand soccer it's just a
mirror of what goes on throughout the
country at any level
[Music]
money
foreign
[Music]
Ada foreign
it turned out that the Togo team was a
fake one and after asking
the Bahrain side who organized the match
they told us it was a company in
Singapore called football for you you
realize that it belonged to one Wilson
Raj perumal the company was a front it
didn't exist and we realized that this
could be something bigger you know as
a frustrating if you if you
if you see things happening they're not
normal and but you cannot actually say
oh that was match fixing because they
don't do it that obviously there are
some people that don't want to do that
some referees but it's got so bad that
some managers actually give money just
so that the referees don't ref against
them and you you refer here's some money
for you to refer you know it just is
horrible as a coach it's just
why do you do that why you train why you
pick players why you keep players happy
why do you uh make amazing speeches like
Braveheart speeches before a game you
know uh it's pointless you know why do
you study leadership and psychology why
do you why do you bother scouting how do
they play and coming up with the with
the with the appropriate tactics and
why bother all of that if in the 80th
minute the referee just says penalty
kick
honey has promised bonus for win today
win bonus
so you have every incentive to win more
money
more fast cars and cheap women
[Applause]
stand up be big strong
under 21's Mitra cooker
strong
okay always stay in front in front in
front
thank you
this is one of the things that annoy me
match match officials Clan Corners he
should have done this before you've got
the players out standing in the heat out
of the dressing room and now he's
talking to them
some [__] self-important match
official
you should have been in the dressing
room 20 minutes before checking the
players and players names that match the
shirts not coming out here and doing it
well all the players are now cooling
down because they're out here they've
just stretched so now they're standing
waiting for some old Koji to sort
himself out and read the names of the
list
here we go thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
is it just me
okay so stop just stop just stop and
listen
okay
five minutes just stop and listen then
we can go no problem
if you think that performance is going
to win us the league you've got another
thing coming
you've got bullied
bullied by 22 21 year old kids
your professional footballers earning
good money and you're oh not tackling
run past
you think we will win like this you
think we win games
no [__] heart
no heart
just oh okay oh okay okay
ahead that's how much they want to win
I'm not happy in the slightest about how
we got bullied every tackle
who hit someone
if you think that is enough
then that's not
concentrate
okay
understand
the first time I met Simon mcmenemy was
on the semi-final of iff 2010 in Jakarta
after the Philippines games and you
become
sort of you know media darling back then
and people like him and yeah then before
you know he become the coach of Mitra
kukar
[Music]
my close friends
I think admire me for making the
decision to give up my job and to come
with Simon to follow his dream I mean
it's a holiday for the first month maybe
two months you're out here it feels like
a holiday the longer you're here
the more people realize that actually
this is your life giving up working two
jobs giving up seeing my friends to and
going to all the way the other side of
the world and not really doing anything
was really hard
foreign
[Music]
Center back the John Terry of Indonesian
football
and we've got bustomi who is the poor
skulls of Indonesian football and we're
still waiting for two more under-23
national team players
and one more foreign Center forward
so starting to get quite excited now
starting to see the squad kind of come
together and it's all
it's all looking rather good
[Laughter]
no no
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
sir
foreign
talking just how he is and who's playing
where he's playing what he's doing and
everything and then um here I'm
explaining a little bit on
do something for me
here is like a just for that I'll get
the money
and then ask where are you now
Jakarta
and I'll talk to you in detail
I know that as of May 2014 there had
been attempts to fix two teams two
matches in the Indonesian Football
League
[Music]
let's listen and this is a three-way
conversation
[Music]
is
that yeah so he mentioned the two teams
here
big money big money
yeah
[Applause]
so if you tell me that it's not
happening people are too afraid to do
things nope
some people are still in the business
and they will do but you know when it
comes down to it it's because it's so
easy to fix game true it's almost like a
business transaction you want to make
money I want to make money too
so yeah it's business
hey hello boys
[Music]
um
for lunch so what time can we meet him
after uh the afternoon after training so
tonight okay
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
um
we're actually offering him a certain
amount of of cash but then he said well
after delay he will take the money after
he's doing a job
for me that's also just like well you
know it's kind of a risky but he only
said no to the the procedure SEC later
it's not actually directly no but just
like not now just later but the way he
took the question the way he entered it
the way talk about it it's it's a very
normal relaxed way you know he becomes a
little bit uncomfortable in some stage
but I think that's because of the the
place where we are it's in a public well
I think he just didn't see it coming
from me
ah
[Music]
this is
foreign
this looks like it's just dropped out of
Europe somewhere it's a European but you
can tell it's Asian at the same time
because it's not looked after
it's five years old and it's dirty
and this is what frustrates me so much
about Asian football is they build these
amazing stadiums like this which is
incredible
considering we're in the middle of the
Jungle three hours from the nearest
airport they build a stadium like this
and then just let it rot
I'd love to see it full which just very
rarely is
foreign
so what happens a lot
is that the mayor appoints a manager
that was involved in his election
campaign and so the manager
uses the club as a platform to make
money
you know and so what he does is he
appoints a coach and he gets a cut from
the coach a certain million and every
player he appoints he get a cut from The
Players
you know and coaches sometimes do that
as well so the coaches and the managers
work together and the the coach get a
cut and the manager get a bigger cut
it's just you know it's it's funny but
it's so sad you know if you can't win
you might as well lose and if you lose
uh hopefully you can lose by such a
score line now if it's been agreed then
that would be the scoreline then the
match fixer with that that information
he will go to his betting operations
illegal betting operations and inform
his superiors that the game is going to
turn out this way so with that knowledge
of the scoreline they were better
whatever amount that that would not
raise any suspicion offers at the top
you have one boss or maybe the most two
they are the ones who will finance the
operations below that you have the
runners or even the lieutenants who will
direct the play at the ground level
there are of course people on the ground
who need to speak to the players to the
officials to corrupt them and these guys
are the ones that have direct contact
with the players and they'll call
football players like 15 16 years old
telling them that hey this is the
today's football this is the Smart Way
of playing football you lose the game
yes but you have something in your
pocket you know for a guy that young
you might not know the consequences but
uh
that's how they work they tell them that
this is today's smart football
Simon actually got told
that a referee had phoned the club
said if you want to guarantee a win it's
going to cost you
however much
someone told Simon and Simon was just
like
not happy and he spoke to the owner
and the owner was like oh well you know
sometimes you have to in order to win
and someone's like no
we're not doing that not while I'm head
coach you know I'm not being any part of
that and the owner was like oh no no yes
of course no no we're not not part of
that and everything and it was
completely brushed aside and forgotten
and it wasn't that but then Simon's
going into that game Thinking will the
other head coach has probably had
exactly the same phone call I don't know
if you said yes or not
so you could be going in there all the
preparation in the world is not gonna
win okay
[Music]
we've still got one game after this to
go and that's away in Papua that'll be a
tough game but it's important you win
your home games so we've got to take
three points today to make sure that we
can go to Papua have a good fight and if
we take the three points there that puts
us at 33 three behind the leader so
fingers crossed that'd be enough
can you tell us about the last condition
from your team uh the team's in very
good condition we have two players who
come back from injury today so we had no
injury problems everyone is 100 fit so
everyone's very confident of the game
today I just get their team Sheet they
have four substitutes
they can't even name seven sub stitutes
quickly with injuries that tells you
they're struggling with suspensions so
that means from minute one you get at
them you don't let them out you don't
give them a break the first tackle the
first header you win but we batter them
batter them batter them batter them
three points push you third we have to
take care of business today
[Music]
[Applause]
stopwatch
[Music]
this team have come here to defend
they've not come here to go forward
they've not come here to score goals for
them is damage limitation
if they can come away with a zero zero
they're happy you get one goal they
crumble they finish
but you have to get that one goal
and we keep the pressure in the final
third
because eventually they'll crack
they are not good enough defensively to
handle you for the whole game
[Applause]
great shot
[Music]
[Applause]
that is a really really difficult one to
take
to dominate the game that much
for one reason or another there was no
luck with us today nothing fell
we've now got to go to Papua travel two
days
driving a bus stay in a crappy Hotel
we've got to go to Papa and take three
points
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
use all the substitution so I cannot
fake an injury but because we talk about
that me letting a goal in then I did
that just I just confirmed in a WhatsApp
the game was very fishy from the
beginning to the end with all the red
car the injuries the goals and house
defended how was how it was being scored
and so on so yeah
I think there's something else happening
in that game
after the game you know I call him this
time he he arranged a place to meet in
the coffee shop in a mall one of the one
of the cafes there so we get there we
have coffee and then I try to offer the
the envelope you know but he said he
didn't want to take it then I think it's
mostly because it's a very crowded place
he doesn't want people to see that there
is a transaction going on let me grab a
cab and then we just drove away and
that's in the cap where it's only me and
him and the driver I handed offer the
money and he took it no question he just
took it and said oh great man thanks uh
you know this is like a bonus and it's
awesome you know it's a blessing you
know like great thank you and it's like
in the back of my head I think he was
kind of hoping that in the in the future
I would have would do the same again to
him
you would like to interview him and ask
him to speak in front of the camera I
mean we'd guarantee all his safety and
everything but he refused it and um
I think the main reason that he didn't
want to talk in front of camera is
basically safety if that is your life
and suddenly you are you saying that
you're part of a scheme and you're doing
that and you're on camera and forever
I'll Hound you you know
[Music]
you not get paid for three months four
months and someone gives you money you
say no no I don't know I will go home I
will my father
yeah we are we are thinking you know I
was thinking first just um no it's good
to show him the footage and let's say
hey man you see you said I've never
taken the the money but here you are you
know and you did take it but at the end
we decided not to just you know because
it's also just um pure for his safety
first or the second that he will go and
Report
um to someone and we will be in trouble
[Music]
yes it seems
you remember
the defense
if they accept this
so right stand around and saying well we
don't practice defensive Corners we
don't
even if we did you don't listen and
performance
[Music]
anyway the point is we didn't play Bad
it's not allowed to play really really
bad
about a management decision tools have
been to other clubs how you think I've
I've not heard anything about this I not
have
uh
uh I don't know
[Music]
all good I'm giving a sec what there's
nothing getting a sec
foreign
[Applause]
in order to the club in order for the
club to develop
they need to bring in new head coach
[Music]
discussion about it the president [__]
up for someone against surgery on a no
one's looking bottles are actually
called the internet
so they sent the values head of police
they let me take training this morning
and then caught us into the stadium
because we didn't reach our Target at
eight points in the last four games so
[Music]
um
I just get you together
for last time
um
some of you know some of you don't know
this more last night management have
meeting
and they decide that's best for mitchuka
that I not continue as coach or Darren
not continuous coach
[Music]
um
I don't know what happens from here for
you guys I'm sure you will be all looked
after with me nothing is ever personal
everything is always football
I said to you first day of season
I will put the best 11 players I have in
my opinion on football field
and if players get left out players get
left out I must deal with that
but you will only ever got left out for
football reason
never for personal reason
you must believe that to be true
thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you
my boss yeah just one new coaching
well if they want they want but just
stay in touch let me know right we go
[Music]
foreign
my target was fifth
just three weeks ago they changed
Target had a meeting with the president
president said in the last four games
the club want me to take eight points
but they didn't say what happened would
happen
if you didn't get eight pointers but
they didn't say get eight points or we
get a sack queue they just that was
something that they wanted you to aim
for
so clear goals weren't set and they're
moving the goal post just because
suddenly a team that they thought would
they'd be happy to finishing fifth are
doing well so they've decided that
actually they want to be greedy and try
and get higher
which is fair enough you can't even sack
the coach if they haven't
perhaps well okay Indonesia
you
play a certain formation
and it's not usual or you put a player
out of position
which is something you do out of because
it's it's necessary tactically they
don't understand it and they they
actually
try to tell you who should be playing we
should not be playing that's a that's a
big turn off as a coach you know either
you trust me or you don't
you trust me and if it doesn't go well
you blame me fine but
that's why I don't want to coach right
now
[Music]
today we're playing um Surabaya bayang
by Ankara United
I mean man I don't even know their name
anymore I've been changing it a lot this
year it's a team owned by police force
in Indonesia so
um I'm gonna expect a lot of police
supporter in the stadium today
I'm in mcmenemy I think I think you got
a culture shock that's how I see it you
know he come with a amazing football
strategy and
tactics and game plan but I think he
missed something about the culture if
Simon probably understand that and
managed to dig into that I think he will
do really good over here
because I mean he he already he he
already people like him
without doubt the most enjoyable part of
this job is standing in front of so many
people every week
standing in front of so many crazy fans
appreciating the passion for your team
and against your team
just witnessing
people going mad over goals and and
penalties and free kicks and
the Pinnacle of the last three years was
the two semi-finals in the buncano in
Jakarta
in front of 90 000 people when an
estimated TV audience of
400 500 million people across southeast
Asia you could work a lifetime and not
get that opportunity and to have
represented a country at the same time
to stand as a head coach with a country
behind you and listening to the national
anthem and knowing that the whole
country's at home willing you on and is
an incredible feeling
okay
I said
maybe in the last four years or five
years where the publicity and the
awareness of match fixing has risen due
to this what it is today there will be
people who are naturally skeptical of
what they are seeing on the screen on
the field and they will question like is
this a fixed match so yes we may have
lost a few souls in terms of fans but
again I think it's for the better that
you know the awareness of match fixing
is out to show that the world is trying
to do something about it
match fixing yeah sure
although it's very difficult to prove
you know it goes on
probably with players probably with
referees
probably with owners
Vietnam you had the problem you know
owners would own three or four clubs in
the same league
so if the team at the bottom of the
league needed to three points not to get
relegated on the last day of the season
they just happened to be playing
the owners other team that's towards the
top of the league you can guarantee who
wins
you have to understand what's going on
around football you have to understand
the personalities and the culture around
football
and then you have to try and slowly work
your own thoughts ideas and
into that mix
and at the same time win games of
football
biggest thing you need to do number one
you've got to make a rule that if you're
involved in politics you cannot be
involved in clubs or in federations
simple but it's hard to do it's big The
Next Step would be to to not allow
Government funding for clubs lots of
clubs would die
but it's better to have a leak made out
of 12 healthy clubs that are not
political not government funded that way
you you don't mix politics with football
that way you take out the corruption and
that way you take out match fixing then
you need Hunters like these guys who go
around the world who behave like match
fixes in terms of searching out targets
and then when it's finally time to
affect an arrest then we open the local
law enforcement that's the only way to
chase these guys
one thing you learn about Asia is that
nothing goes your way and that you have
to roll with the punches and make the
best of every situation you have to
remember that you're number one and you
have to look out for yourself
and if you can keep your morals intact
while you're doing that and that's just
a bonus
[Music]
will happen in Europe in South America
in either part of Asia and Africa
well I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure the same
thing happens it's just you know you
just you just gotta prove it the
supporters out there are just giving all
their heart out to sing to jump and you
know and if at the end the game is just
being corrupted being fixed so what's
the point of having a football game
really you want to have a you want to
have a clean game
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
God
Larry Larry
[Music]
go
please
[Music]